the Joe Rogan experience but you gotta
know where you're at to like getting
fired from me we got kicked off Opie and
Anthony in 2002 best thing that ever
happened to me because it showed me that
can all be taken away from you so long
before this whole culture of just
canceled culture and all this [ __ ]
happened I had had that moment of life
is good and then you're out it was a cut
the Condoleezza Rice thing right no that
was on XM that's when we almost got
fired from satellite no this was a set
for salmon on terrestrial this is wneud
oh oh that's when you guys get fired
because you had the people and they had
sex in a little section st. pat's yeah
so that was two years off the air but
that showed me that they can take
anything at any time
yeah so I've never thought I was
irreplaceable I'd never think I'm I got
it forever anything I have I know you
know can be [ __ ] yanked immediately
ya know it definitely can that was a
weird one to me because the big thing
was that these people had sex in a
Catholic cathedral that was the the big
reason why they got fired right because
they didn't ask these people to do it in
there did they yeah it was kind of a
contest it was known like you would get
what they call a two-point conversion if
you had anal like there was all these
weird things and it was a bad move to go
in the same path thing when the st.
Pat's and there was an arrest and
because there was an arrest it became
real and it was so avoidable on so many
levels like so many things yeah you look
back you know why did we just shut the
[ __ ] up and it would have stopped you
know you know why do we push it but you
know I'm glad it happen now in hindsight
well you know in a lot of ways it's
there's this thing that people do you
know we're talking about re before the
podcast where it's you do things you're
not supposed to do so people go I can't
believe you're doing that and then
there's just like thrill to that there's
a thrill to it and then what happens is
you have to keep upping it yeah you have
to keep upping it yes and it's almost
like you get a fear like if I don't top
last time the people who like me are no
longer gonna like me and I'm gonna lose
this momentum I've picked up you become
afraid that the people who like you are
gonna go you're a fraud you're not doing
what we want you to do then you keep
topping yourself and keep topping it
it's like the kid who eats bugs you know
what I mean you know then he's eating a
roach and the next thing you know he's
[ __ ] these
doing this because he's afraid of not
topping himself and all the sudden being
ignored bright like pat like the intern
Pat oh yeah pat tuffy
Pat Duffy best peek a cat [ __ ] he drank
people's vomit he was literally an
indestructible [ __ ] man if you if you
have to build a guys and like in a
military he's a type of mentality you
want oh yeah for sure you want to get
him when he's 18
yeah turn him into a full salvage yeah
what is he doing these days I don't know
I haven't talked to him I don't know
what about Pat from wound Aki you know I
thought of him recently he had on
Twitter I don't know exactly I would
love to have him yeah Pat Philbin his
name is I would love to have him on to
our radio show because I miss Pat from
Moonachie a lot dude that day where he
did the baby bird the day where they had
the eggnog dream contest it was you and
me and BER and Ari and there was a
couple other people in the studio as
well yeah that was one of my most fun
times ever on the radio she's so
ridiculous the whole floor you could
never do that today never never in a
million years
we're in Opie and Anthony in the studio
the floor was covered in plastic bags
because they had an opening an open
Anthony had an eggnog eating contest and
everyone would throw up there's you get
to a certain level of eggnog we just
couldn't take it anymore and Pat had to
throw up because he was diabetic so he
shouldn't been drinking that anyway we
should so he's drinking gallons and
gallons of eggnog and when he threw it
up we said like he was ready to go and I
said let's get Pat Duffy to lean his
head was that your suggestion yeah I was
doing fear factor back then I my my head
was all full of sick things that was
like what year was that mm I want to say
eighteen seven wasn't really together on
that was on k-rock that was in a
terrestrial studio was it seven yes I'm
thinking it was yeah it definitely
wasn't three because we weren't on the
raw on the radio then oh right right
right um so he leans his head over this
garbage pail and Pat from Moonachie
blows judge like a fountain like the
most insane Stephen King like who was
that movie stand by me remember the kid
had a pie-eating contest and kids throw
yeah that's what it was like
didn't seem humanly possible that a
person could have that much fluid in
their body and then when he was
injecting it was like a cartoon he's
doing it in Pat's face mm 6 mm so it's
2006 Wow
and I can't believe I forgot I used to
forget that that burro was there that
day yeah we're all there moon it's one
of those things you're glad you were
part of right like I'm happy I was there
for that I was happy I got to see that
it was so fun that show when it was in
its prime when it was in its peak was so
fun yeah and it was it was a hang and it
really influenced in a lot of ways the
way I do podcasts because it's there's
no structure it's just hanging out with
funny people I'm just talking about
stuff no structure yeah just
bullshitting wherever it goes it goes I
mean it'll only go somewhere I mean
example gave me a conversation it's
always gonna flow somewhere exactly
there's nothing to be controlled and
regimented and what do you wanna talk is
there anything worse when you go to a
radio show like what do you want - dude
I've done radio show so they tell you
they want you to bring up certain
subjects where you have jokes you know
there's not even that long ago man like
less than 10 years ago I did one of
those national radio shows in the
Midwest and they asked me to do that and
I was like what and the producer got
upset and I go I don't do that okay I'm
not gonna do that and like we need
subjects like the guy was like pissy
with me yeah it's hard to do because you
feel embarrassed it's like prot you feel
just you feel dirty like when someone's
doing your bit and you know you're doing
it they're high they're fake laughing
who's enjoying this that's what radio
used to be though what radio used to be
like you'd go on WAAF
in Boston and you know you would talk to
the guys and you would kind of work in
your bits yeah you know and like
everybody did it everybody did their
bits yeah I guess it was a part of it
but I was never good at it well because
you're authentic but Opie and Anthony
was the first to me like Howard show was
much more controlled you know Howard's
behind the mixer he's kind of
controlling everything there's a certain
amount of time that he would talk to you
and then other people would come in and
then you know he had like a more more of
a structure whereas ona you would go in
there and Anthony would have a gun and
[ __ ] you know Oh
Opie's behind the mixer just sort of
watching all this chaos go on different
comics come filtering in and you know
every time Mary
Barry walked in yeah he was going on
swaye next door and we he was like a
little out of it and loopy and we
[ __ ] we just hijacked them and it
kind of walked in like he had no idea
who we were it was really uncomfortable
about crack he went right into you it
was in that pipe it was like nobody
knows what's in that fight I go nobody
knows what's in that plan I'm like you
knew what's in that pipe [ __ ] you
talking about man and the publicist
would come on let's go they wanted to
get a matter they wanted to get him out
of there immediately yeah that was fun
Marion Barry he died not too long after
that I don't think right it wasn't that
long after that yeah it was funny man I
remember there was a an interview they
did where there was a news station they
were talking about to people about his
arrest and all this stuff and they
interview this guy goes call come on man
everybody smokes a little crack every
now and then I'm like everybody smokes a
little crack every now and then that's a
great quote from a mayor that's a great
mayor's who wasn't him though he wasn't
saying it someone else okay in defense
of him or if it was him saying that that
would be hilarious yeah Mike have I
missed no it was another guy that was on
the street who was like everybody smokes
a little crack every now and then did he
get reelected after that Jesse did I
think he went to jail came out and got
reelected yeah yes people DC very
forgiving lol yeah yes forgiving it
strange [ __ ] placement
[Applause]